in der Südukraine ist der Staudamm von
kachowka gebrochen seit gestern Nacht
strömen riesige Wassermassen in den
Fluss
weite Teile des Gebietes um den
Grenzfluss sind überflutet auf der einen
Seite ist die Ukraine auf der anderen
Seite die vom russischen Militär
besetzten Landesteile die Menschen haben
sich in Dutzenden Ortschaften und
Dörfern retten müssen und immer noch
lässt sich nicht sagen wie lange das
Wasser noch steigt es ist aus mehreren
Perspektiven eine Katastrophe für die
Landwirtschaft denn die Felder sind
verloren für die Menschen die ihre
Häuser verloren haben und auch für die
Natur und die Umwelt da lassen sich die
Folgen noch gar nicht abschätzen es ist
nicht das erste Mal dass so etwas
passiert dieses Mal werfen sich die
Ukraine und Russland gegenseitig vor den
Damm beschädigt zu haben aber in der
Geschichte gab es eben schon den einen
oder anderen Vorfall und zwar 1941
sprengte die Rote Armee einen riesigen
Darm im ukrainischen saporesia auch am
Fluss um den Vorstoß der deutschen
Wehrmacht aufzuhalten mindestens 20.000
Menschen sollen damals ums Leben
gekommen sein darüber kann ich jetzt
sprechen mit Professor Sönke Neitzel von
der Uni Potsdam konfliktforscher und
Militärhistoriker
hallo
wie sehen Sie die historischen Bilder
gibt es da Parallelen und welche
parallelen sehen Sie
na wenn wir die Bilder jetzt von dem
zerstörten Damm sehen sie haben es in
der Moderation ja gesagt dann kommen
einem Historiker die Bilder von Augustus
seit 41 in Erinnerung als ganz in der
Nähe im Dio zurückziehen eine Rote Armee
diesen Damm gesprengt hat die Deutschen
haben ihn dann wieder aufgebaut bis 1943
und haben ihn dann im Herbst 43 bei
ihrem Rückzug auch wieder gesprengt und
das ist die unmittelbare parallele ähm
und wir haben natürlich dann auch in
anderen Phasen gerade das erste und
Zweiten Weltkrieges durchaus den Einsatz
von Wasser als Waffe also wir haben
mehrere Fälle wo Dämme gebrochen wurden
und wo man auch gezielt Überflutungen
eingesetzt hat um feindliche vormärsche
aufzuhalten Stichwort Wasser als Wasser
was für eine Rolle haben diese Angriffe
auf die Dämme gespielt militärisch
gesehen
ja wir haben jetzt eine große mediale
Aufmerksamkeit aber ich würde sagen
obwohl das natürlich jetzt schrecklich
ist für die Leute die da betroffen sind
wir sollten es insgesamt für den
Kriegsverlauf nicht überbewerten ich
glaube auch jetzt dass dieser ganz
aktuell das für den Kriegsverlauf keine
keine sehr große Rolle spielt so schlimm
das ist für die Menschen die davon
betroffen sind aber ich glaube das
ukrainische gegen offensiven jetzt nicht
im Wesentlichen davon betroffen sind
dies wird glaube ich an anderen Orten
stattfinden und noch historisch gesehen
haben wenn das Jahr 1941 zurückgehen
dann ist auch der Vormarsch da wer macht
damals dadurch nicht wesentlich
aufgehalten worden die Wehrmacht ist ein
anderer Stelle über den jepper gegangen
es gab eine Beeinflussung weil man wie
damals wie heute Strom erzeugt hat mit
diesen stauding aber auch das konnte die
Wehrmacht zumindest etwas wieder
entstand setzen so dass es nicht zum
völligen Blackout kam also es hat eine
Einfluss aber der Einfluss ist insgesamt
auf einen Krieg betrachtet
vergleichsweise begrenzt zumindest jetzt
diese beiden
Ampere was ist denn aus ihrer Sicht die
wahrscheinlichste Ursache für den
Dammbruch jetzt und welches Szenarien
sind vorstellbar
also da können wir jetzt von hier aus
von Potsdam spreche ich nur noch
spekulieren also das sieht alles so aus
als ob die russische Seite die ja auch
den Damm vermiet hat das gezündet hat
dass man vielleicht
das wäre dann das was am
wahrscheinlichsten ist sagte er es gibt
schon natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass die Ukraine auch an einer
unwahrscheinlichen Stelle angreifen
nämlich über den jepper hinweg und dass
das damit für die ukrainische Seite
erschwert wird was aber wirklich
dahinter steht ähm also wir können uns
Gedanken machen letztlich um das genau
zu beurteilen müsste man eben die
russische Seite kennen und das ist deine
Aufgabe für zukünftige Historiker das
ist jetzt heute an diesem Moment
letztlich Spekulation
kurz noch mal zurückblickt die
ukrainische Seite hat zu Beginn des
Krieges einen kleineren Damen bei Kiew
gesprengt um den russischen Format zu
stoppen wie würde sich das aus
militärischer Sicht und aus ihrer Sicht
von einem möglichen russischen
sprengeneinsatz unterscheiden
naja also die Sache bei ihr pingen im
Norden von von Kiew damit hat man einen
Damm gesprengt um um eine firmastraße um
den Vormarsch sagen zu verlangsamen auch
da haben wir hatten einen Kauf genommen
dass landwirtschaftliche Flächen
überflutet werden
also beide Seiten setzen solche Waffen
ein um Wasser zu sagen und die jeweilige
gegnerische Seite zu bremsen also
insofern ist das ist das Sagen moralisch
ja wie wenn man das bewerten die Ukraine
haben uns sagen selber getan und hier
ist es dann sind das russische
Streitkräfte die auf dem Gebiet eines
eines anderen Staates in dieses
Territorium eingedrungen sind und
niemand hat sie eingeladen sie
verteidigen ähm nicht ihren eigenen
Staat sondern sie führen
aggressionskrieger also da ist es ein
Unterschied aber die Folge für
Landwirtschaft und Menschen in
gleichermaßen natürlich negativ ist
wobei wir eben im ersten ukrainischen
Fall ist es eine viel kleinere
Überflutung als wir sie jetzt haben
ähm also von daher ist es sicherlich
rein rechtlich na dann einen Unterschied
die parallele ist dass man Wasser als
Wasser einsetzt als Unterstützung für
die eigene Krieg Führung
und dann schließe ich gleich die nächste
Frage an wem nutzt denn jetzt diese
Katastrophe diese Überflutungen diese
Überschwemmungen wer kann davon
profitieren kann überhaupt jemand davon
profitieren
also ich zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ist also
ein wirklicher namhafter nutzen nicht
recht absehbar also im AKW wird es ja
wohl so sein ich kann auch dann nur die
Meldung wiedergeben die jeder von uns
lesen kann dass die Kühlwasserversorgung
zunächst zumindest ähm
gewährleistet ist ich kann nicht sehen
dass eine ukrainische gegen Offensive
dadurch wesentlich behindert wird weil
ich glaube nicht dass das dieser Ort
wirklich der geostrategische
entscheidende Punkt ist an dem die
Ukraine einen Gegenangriff planen das
ist viel weiter im Osten ähm und das ist
ich sehe das eher als ein Teil dieser
psychologischen Kriegsführung ein Teil
der Vorbereitung
die Ukraine will eingehen eine gegen
Offensive führen die Russen versuchen
genau das zu verhindern was beide Seiten
wie die wie das Kalkül bei der Seiten
ist was man wie warum macht das können
wir eigentlich nur von außen ja da
können wir Rätselraten aber das führt
letztlich nicht sehr viel weiter ich
glaube aus meiner Sicht jetzt nicht das
irgendeine Seite dadurch einen
entscheidenden militärischen Vorteil und
wie komme ich zu dem Argument wenn wir
mal zurückblicken in die Geschichte und
sehen in welchen Fällen Wasser als Waffe
eingesetzt worden ist wir haben Fälle es
hat 43 haben zum Beispiel die Alliierten
die Möhne und Edertalsperre mit mit
Bomben zerstört wir haben den Fall von
1914 der vielleicht gar nicht so bekannt
ist dass die Belgier die Briten
Schleusen geöffnet haben um Newport in
den belgische am Hafenstadt im Gebiete
zu überfluten und diese Stadt besser
verteidigen zu können wir haben die
Insel weicheren 1944 wo Briten Dämme
Stauden ähm Dame gesprengt haben und
dann die Insel halt überflutet wurde so
dass die Deutschen die nicht so gut
verteidigen konnten also all diese Fälle
haben durchaus ein lokalen Einfluss
gehabt die haben in einigen Fällen sogar
wie bei der Müller Edertalsperre 100
oder 1000 Menschen getötet aber sie
haben eigentlich keinen namhaften
Verlauf auf den auf den Krieg genommen
so vielen Faktoren abhängig dass das
eigentlich ähm ja man muss so schlimm
das für die Leute ist letztlich im
gesamten Kriegsverlauf Fußnoten sind
noch mal ich will sagen das nicht gering
erachten für die Menschen die darunter
betroffen sind die auch zu Tode kommen
dadurch aber das ist jetzt nicht ein
Faktor der der den Kriegsverlauf
entscheidend beeinflusst das war es auch
in der in der Geschichte nicht also wenn
wir den Verein von 1914 von Newport
nehmen das Öffnen der Schleusen und
Flandern dann hat das sicherlich in
deutschen Angriff in Flandern im Herbst
und seit 14 auch verlangsamt auch
erschwert aber selbst wenn man das nicht
gemacht hätte hätten die Deutschen 14
den Krieg nicht gewonnen also das ähm
die Offensive war im Prinzip schon
gescheitert also von daher müssen wir es
ein bisschen eingrenzen und sagen das
sind letztlich ähm
schlimme Radikalisierung es ist ähm es
ist hier sozusagen die Umwelt wird
sozusagen als Teil der Waffe verwendet
es sind wichtige Infrastrukturen die
natürlich nach dem Krieg wieder
aufgebaut werden müssen enorme Kosten
die verursacht werden aber für den Krieg
sind andere Dinge entscheidend
was sind denn militärisch gesehen die
mittelfristigen und auch die
längerfristigen Folgen dieses
ja ich bin kein Agraringenieur also das
ist müsste man dann konkret fragen was
sind die Folgen auch dieser
Überflutungen es ist immerhin Süßwasser
und kann Salzwasser wie 1914 bei den
Feldern in Flandern aber dass das
dieser
militärisch gesehen also dieses ganze
Wasser was bedeutet das jetzt für für
jede militärische Bewegung auf diesen
Gebieten in diesen Gebieten
also dicht Überflutung wird eine
militärische Bewegung natürlich sehr
Schwert gerade in Zeiten wo wir mit
motorisierten Fahrzeugen unterwegs sind
aber dass man entscheiden das Argument
ist das eigentlich das nicht diese
Region aus dieser Region eigentlich
keine wirklichen Operationen geführt
werden nicht also wir sind direkt am
jepper einem der größten Ströme Europas
und es ist sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
dass die Ukraine über diesen Fluss
hinweg ein angriffsschlagieren genauso
wenig wie es eben jetzt unwahrscheinlich
ist dass die Russen über diesen Fluss
hinweg angreifen sie haben sich ja
gerade aus der Sonne zurückgezogen also
Überflutungen behindern militärische
Bewegungen machen sie unmöglich aber das
ist alles an einem Ort an einer Stelle
wo meines Erachtens gar keine
entscheidenden Operation stattfinden
werden von daher sind die Folgen für den
Kriegsverlauf aus diesem Grund glaube
ich gering einzuschätzen
sie haben es ja schon erwähnt die die
Folgen oder Zerstörung von Infrastruktur
speziell von Dämmen war nicht wirklich
erfolgsversprechend in der Geschichte
warum macht man das dann überhaupt man
ist ja eigentlich egal ob als
Besatzungsmacht oder als Verteidiger ist
man ja auf Infrastruktur angewiesen
warum also solche Angriffe also die das
Kalkül ich gehe jetzt mal von einer
russischen Täterschaft bei diesem
Dammbruch aus das Kalkül der Russen
können wir nicht genau einschätzen das
ist Mutmaßung in den Dammbruch den sie
in ihrer Moderation kurz erwähnt haben
nördlich von hier da war es einfach ein
Abwägen im wie kann man den Vormarsch
der Russen möglichst verzögern gegen
sagen Überflutung von Feldern
landwirtschaftliche Schäden und da hat
ähm die Ukraine gesagt die das Aufhalten
der Russen ist jetzt ein höheres Gut und
es hat sicherlich damals dann im Februar
22 auch dazu beigetragen beigetragen den
russischen Vormarsch zu verzögern also
es ist immer eine Abwägung der der
verschiedenen Maßnahmen vielen Dank für
das Interview
herzlichen Dank